-Guys, it is time for
"Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."
Check it out.
-♪ "Good Names, Bad Names,
Great Names" ♪
♪ Yes ♪
-First up, we have "Peacemaker."
That is a good name
for a superhero.
That is a bad name for
Vladimir Putin.
It is a great name for the
person in the group chat
who actually picks
a dinner location.
"Hey! We got a place.
We're going. We're going."
After that,
we have One Direction.
That's a good name for a band.
That is a bad name
for an elevator.
It's a great name
for a laxative.
Oh, interesting.
-Wow!
-Next, we have Half Baked.
Well, that is a good name for a
Ben & Jerry's flavor.
It's a bad name for a pizzeria.
It's a great name for Snoop Dogg
and Martha Stewart.
That's very well done.
After that, there's "All In."
Well, that is a good name for
an MSNBC show,
a bad name for a hotel Jacuzzi,
a great name
for your dentist's hands.
There you go, everybody.
I used to have a dentist.
I love him. Dr. Smigel.
-Oh, yeah.
-Robert Smigel's dad.
-Yeah.
-The greatest dentist.
I loved him so much, and he
would stick his fingers
in my mouth before
I even got my jacket off.
I'd walk in.
He'd be like,
"Jimmy, how are you doing?"
I go, "I'm great."
And he's like, "Let me --"
And I go, "Alright."
I go, "Wait. Hold on a second."
Just stop."
He just loved it.
He loved what he did.
I loved him so much.
He was awesome.
What are you doing, man?
He's so funny.
And then he -- we were talking.
He was drilling
or doing something
or cleaning or something.
And I'm sitting there
in the chair,
and he was talking about --
Someone said something about --
Or there was a photo of
a newscaster that was
on his wall.
Before the procedure,
I go, "I love her.
Oh, my God. She's the best."
I love --"
No, I won't say her name.
He's like, "Yeah, she's great."
So, I'm in the thing.
And he leaves,
and I'm just waiting there.
And then he walks back in
and he goes,
"This is --"
and just introduced me to her
as I was just in the chair.
This is a true story.
I got to work on it,
but it's real.
-Yeah. She was
in the waiting room.
-What?
-She was there.
-Yeah, she came in
with him just to --
She was like, "I guess
I'll say hi to Jimmy Fallon.
I don't know."
My mouth is wide open,
all these things.
I go, "Hey, how's it going?"
Next, there is
"The Desperate Hour."
Well, that is a good name for
a thriller movie.
It's a bad name for
the bathroom line at Chipotle.
-Oh!
-And it is a great name for
a bar at 1:45 a.m.
Next up, there's Nutty Buddy.
Well, that's a good name for
a peanut-butter cookie.
That's a bad name
for an allergy medication.
It's a great name for
a jockstrap.
Finally, we have "Warzone."
Well, that is a good name for a
"Call of Duty" game.
And it's a bad name for
a daycare center.
It's a great name for
the milk station at Starbucks.
That is exactly right.
That's all for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."